CBS News legal analyst Ricky Clayman
joins us from San Francisco Ricky good
morning in this trial the judge let
other accusers testify was that the key
that was the key that at the time of the
ruling it really was the death knell for
Bill Cosby pretrial in the first trial
which ended in a hung jury you had one
other accuser who was trying to
supplement what could be considered in
that day and age a weaker case of Andrea
constant in today's world of me too you
had entered a constant story with an
explanation from a rape trauma expert as
to why people continued relationships
with the person they've accused why they
contact them why they may be with them
again when that's bolstered by five
others to try and show a common scheme
or plan where he would lure them into an
environment he controlled where he would
drug them and then take advantage of
them by indecently sexually assaulting
them you can't beat six accusers Cosby's
team says that they will appeal what are
the grounds for appeal here well the
appeal is hardly frivolous they have
many many grounds starting with the fact
that the same judge who knew he had a
hung jury with one other accuser then
entered with five you can go all the way
back Gale all the way back to when Bill
Cosby was promised he says that he would
not be prosecuted therefore he took
place in a civil deposition in a civil
suit where he made statements which were
then in a seal of deposition which came
into this case including the fact that
he had gotten prescriptions for
quaaludes back in the day what he wanted
to have sex with women you also have
issues about evidence that the defense
thought was exculpatory including other
witnesses that was excluded and then of
course we have issues about the jurors
including a juror who allegedly said
that he thought Cosby was guilty before
the trial actually began this will be a
formidable appeal does not mean it will
be successful Ricky time and a
during this trial Bill Cosby's attorneys
attacked these women with blistering
personal attacks calling them a con
artist a pathological liar
in the midst of this me to movement that
those backfire well the defense has no
choice in the sense that they have to
cross-examine being cross-examination is
the great engine of truth but it depends
on how you cross-examine so you didn't
have to only show one was lying you had
to show six we're live in the era of the
me2 movement when a woman's accusation
alone is presumed to be true to
denigrate these women to eviscerate
these women certainly could not sit well
with certain of these jurors it did not
sit well with the public and that had to
be the elephant in this room people
don't want women who may have been
sexually assaulted harassed or abused
whether it was yesterday or 30 years ago
to have to go through something like
this but after all it's the American
jury system all right thanks so much
Ricky Clayman